there is reason to believe that together
we may be slowing down this devastating
pandemic there are now more than 430 mm
reported cases in the u.s. at least
fourteen thousand eight hundred people
have died and that may be an
underestimate because of a lack of
testing but take a look at this on
Sunday one widely one widely cited model
predicted at least eighty one thousand
Americans will die in this outbreak by
August with a peak around April
sixteenth but Anthony just two days
later that projection dropped to around
60,000 peaking four days sooner than
expected yeah that model is optimistic
compared to some others Gail and perhaps
for that reason it's favored by the
White House which is eager to reopen
businesses across the country our lead
national correspondent David Beck knows
in New York City near the US Navy
hospital ship comfort David how many
patients are on that ship now only 60
Anthony and I was just talking to the
Navy about why the count is so low they
were explaining to me they've got 1,000
beds on board and of those 1,000 they
have sectioned off 500 to treat Kovac
patients so I'm trying to get an answer
as to why the count is so low because we
keep hearing that the hospitals need
help getting patients here to take some
pressure off the hospital so we'll work
to get an answer on that
in all fairness hospitalizations are
down and continue to go down even though
New York just had the deadliest day yeah
the bad news isn't just bad the bad news
is actually terrible highest single day
death toll yet 779 people yet another
sobering report from New York Governor
Andrew Cuomo but he did add a silver
lining there's no doubt that we are now
bending the curve and there's no doubt
that we can't stop doing what we're
doing that's a good news as that curve
flattens concern for those enforcing law
and order remains high the NYPD says a
15th member of the force has died 2,500
are infected nearly 20% of the force is
out sick in Chicago overburdened
hospitals already dealing with Kovan 19
patients have now had to contend with
more gun violence seven people were shot
to death in that city Tuesday 14 more
were wounded including a five-year-old
girl Lori Lightfoot is the mayor of
Chicago if our ICU are filled with
gunshot victims our ability to respond
to this Kovac 19 crisis will necessarily
be compromised Chicago's Cook County
Jail reportedly has the highest number
of cases that can be traced back to a
single site that's more than the nursing
home in Kirkland Washington where the
coronavirus crisis started the jail's
active cases now number more than 400
although many nonviolent offenders have
been freed protesters on Tuesday
demanded a mass release of inmates after
one of them died from Kovan 19 Cook
County Sheriff says shutting down the
jail is not an option I certainly can't
call the Chicago Police Department say
listen those people you picked up for
murder last night those brutal murders
yeah just keep them locked up in your
office handcuff him to a desk
in Southern California's Riverside
County 84 patients were moved from the
Magnolia nursing Center there are 34
cases of kovat 19 among the residents
five among the employees the patients
had to be relocated after employees
there refused to show up for a second
straight day
I think their fear might have led them
to make a decision that might not have
been the right decision for their
patient the state of California
announced recently that it was going to
send 500 ventilators to states around
the country that needed them and the
governor of new jersey tweeted yesterday
that the ventilators arrived with a
handwritten note and what was written
was prayers from the West Coast and Tony
they're arriving at the right time
because we're told that federal
stockpile which the federal government
runs and stocks is practically empty
just in time indeed David thank you very
much